hi and welcome back to another video one
thing I have personally come to like so
much about a solar system is the fact
that you can always start small and then
go back later so starting small has to
do with the number of um solar panels as
well as batteries and then other
accessories you might need and then you
are always able to upgrade
um data to you know a bigger package or
solution so you could record that when
we were approaching electricity phase
like get electricity for this house and
we decide to consider Sula we're able to
start small that was starting with two
batteries two panels and then added so
in today's video let's talk about the
upgrade of our solar system
foreign
[Music]
so as I was saying earlier we started
off with a solar system with just two
batteries that was a 100 age batteries
each so that gave us like 200 amp hours
and then also I have two panels of each
that was some 182 watts each that was
360 watt of panels that was what we got
and then we had the inverter that was 3
KVA or 3000 watts of inverter there's
some few other accessories now that
particular solution wasn't able to power
much as of then I was basically you know
to help us test the electrical system
that we've had installed and then to use
some few power tools so it was able to
power up some few parties not for a long
time you know we had to regulate how
we're using those parts too so that we
don't run completely out of battery as
at then so that particular solution as
you could record in some of my videos
was around
6600 cities plus they're about that's
what it costs for that particular
solution having the two panels two
batteries and then one inverter there's
some few other accessories to you know
get started that and then aside from
that when we continue working on this
house and then you got to a point where
we needed more to use more power tools
uh there was a need to upgrade from that
particular solution to something higher
so that meant that we had to go in for
two additional batteries that was 100
age each and then two more panels and
then also some few accessories to help
with that particular upgrade so going
about that upgrade also that cost around
9000 plus their button so we upgraded
from 6600 to around 9000 plus that but
we spent like around 30 000 Plus for
that particular upgrade house for the
battery that is two batteries that is um
100 age each and then white watts of
panels each now during that particular
upgrade also going about the upgrade was
it was very necessary to take into
consideration you know the angle of the
sound where the sun comes from where it
rises and the rest so we ended up
installing those two panels on the other
side of the building so their first two
panels went to the side of the building
and then the other two went to this side
of the uh building the reason was we
normally have the sun rises from this
place and then set around this place so
when it sunrises it takes you know a
long time for it to get to this point
too I said even though we're getting
good amounts of sun energy we're still
losing Samsung I didn't have those two
panels over here I was able to you know
help
um get you know good amount of energy
for their batteries now that solution
also was given us around 720 watts of
panels solution or energy from them
solar panels and then also around 400
amp hours from the battery so that was
like the energy were able to get acid
and then that it cost like around
um was upgraded to around 9000
now when it got to a point where we were
down with the building and we had to
move in there was also a need to upgrade
but we took time to upgrade to that
particularly sure the current solution
we have now because after then the
solution we had was able to power up our
fridge was able to power up TV
um water pump and then the lights and
then the fan in the house however I
wasn't able to pop uh that is especially
in the fridge 24 hours because during
the daytime of course the solar panel
um is able to also supply energy to
whatever devices that we are using
whenever the Sun is up or even during
the daylight that we have so that means
that we're going to pop our fridge from
like early morning from around six
o'clock to around four or five PM I get
into the evening then we have to turn it
up because if we keep it on it means
that
um some of the energy which would have
have to start and use in the evening
room have to be cut off so that's how
we're regulating that and so we got the
final upgrade and also during then we
were able to pop all the lights outside
um the house yeah throughout the evening
until the next morning and we're also
not watching so much of tele I'm not
really so much of a TV person so that
was how we're going about it and then um
the water pump we use it as well we need
if you want to get water in the house
and there isn't so much pressure from
the tank then you just turned part of
the pumping machine and that was mostly
during the daytime so we're not using I
have that pump doing that evening time
so that was how we went about uh the
second phase of our upgrade we were able
to manage situations until we go to the
Final Phase or not necessarily find out
but to the current stage of our upgrade
so the current stage of our upgrade has
two 200 h batteries so instead of
additional 100 eh we added to 208 so
that gives us an additional 408 and 400
amp hours so adding it to whatever we
had what we had earlier that was 400
basically now 800 hours and then we also
added two more panels that is 180 watts
of panels so that also gives us a total
of 1080 watts of um solar you know
energy or energy which is being drawn
from the solar panels so as you can see
talking about the upgrade especially
with regard to the solar panels we've
sticked to the same wattage of solar
panels so we started 180 Watt and all
our upgrade has been with 180 Watts so
so that is an important consideration
especially when you have a certain
solution of solar system and you want to
upgrade it's always advisable
recommended to stick to the same size of
their panels yeah especially the panels
but for the batteries we're able to
upgrade from 100 age to 200 h this time
around now that solution or this current
solutionary we have has brought the
total solar cost up to around seven
seventeen thousand five Android City so
it means that we spend around 8 500
about for this particular solution that
was because one of the 108 watch and 200
age batteries was selling for like
around two thousand four hundred they're
about and then you have to buy two more
panels and I had to get a rails and then
um the other accessories that I needed
and then the mc4 connectors and then the
cables and so on so that brought the
total um upgrade to like around that
um amount and the current upgrade we
have is able to take almost everything
that we have in the house so the fridge
is now able to Pop 24 hours without any
challenges we don't have to tear it off
at any point I'm able to use part two so
you saw me do some DIY works here
um with the first few racks I was using
my parts when I was there
um grinding machine using it as a
sandpaper machine and then I even have
worked on another DIY project which is
like a small dining table which I'll
share with you later and I was able to
use a circular saw also which takes
consumes about
1200 watts of energy so I was able to
use that throughout the entire project
and be able to use our pump be able to
use our ion we're able to turn on the
lights you're able to use fans yeah so
everything we have in the house the
current solution that we have is able to
pop everything so like I'm saying this
has only been possible because of the
solar system and we started small we
upgraded to certain points and now we've
upgraded to what we have now if in
future there's a need to upgrade it's
still going to be easier because you're
able to add up more panels to it as well
as add a battery to
um whatever we have now also adding up
there two more panels to our solar
system we had to add it to this
particular point where the sun rises
from so it's able to draw much energy as
compared to where the sun sets or you
know
um yeah from the middle point to where
the sun sets so basically that's the
current solar system that we have the
total cost is around 17 500 cities for
six one else
for Batteries you know six batteries so
four of them are 100 each other two of
them are 200 each so another important
consideration also especially with the
solar upgrade was that um the outside
lights that we had that was a LED light
outside acid then was 50 watts each so
that means that uh when we turn on all
the lights that was like around 200
watts and that was a lot so there was a
need to also change those ones to
something which was a little lower So
currently what we have each of them are
10 watts each so that gives us a little
total of like 40 watt so 200 watts to 40
Watts that's okay and the brightness is
not so like not so bad especially what
we have like a brightness is very very
okay in the evening so that is also an
important consider we needed to take
into action so we don't consume so much
of energy that we have you know solar
energy is a little bit unlimited there's
no unlimited as compared to maybe
um the they're great and even the grid
is also Limited at some point but you
only feel it when it gets to a crucial
point when it has to be load shedding so
that was also an important consideration
we had to take
um interaction um especially with the
outside lights also one of the reasons
why the cost has increased a little bit
was because of changing prices asset you
know this dollar situation that we've
had for some time now for inflation so
prices of goods has you know gone up so
much High the amount we bought the first
point was the first set of panels for we
didn't get the same amount for the
second set of panels and even the last
set of panels also was different prices
the same with the batteries the amount
you got it too much the first two
batteries was different from the second
set of batteries and then also the final
set of batteries also was um different
and then with the cables the mc4
connectors and everything so in as much
as it might look a little bit expensive
because we have done this over like a
period it hasn't been so expensive and
at least it's it's been wetted I must
say because we've been here now like
officially three months now and if we
were supposed to be paying electricity
bill I said now we would have had to
spend like around 600 or 8 close to 800
cities for electricity based on the
things that we have
um here so that is not so but I believe
that in probably some few years to come
it's really going to pay off
um and I'm even sure there's going to be
some increment to electricity or utility
type so
yeah the solar system so far has been
good all we just need is just energy
from the Sun or daylight and we are good
to go so I've also been nominated for
the UT greatest Awards and their
category of um real estates now there
are what is happening sometime in
November so I'm going to leave a link in
the description so you can kindly try to
vote for me thank you very much so that
would be just about it for this
particular video maybe you might have
some questions or things that you which
was not so clear you can just leave them
in the comment section and I'll try as
much as possible to respond to them so
that'll be just about it for this video
thank you very much for watching bye for
now